[Music]  did you know that there were a lot of  dinosaur species in skull island the one  from the 2005 movie of course we saw  just a few and even defeated on wasn't a  dinosaur but a reptile more related to  the crocodilians but out of the three or  four species we saw there were about 20  more that were not shown yet are  documented as part of the island in the  book the world of gong so here in this  video we will showcase them all and in  the next one we will compile all the  large creatures of the island so here in  this video we will only showcase  dinosaurs of that island so hit that  subscribe button and now let's get down  with it  so i hope you have enjoyed watching this  video anyway with that we come to the  end of it so do hit that like button for  support and subscribe as well to be a  part of the mind cue family but most of  all smash the bell icon for regular  updates on new videos right here on this  channel till the next one take care fam  you